thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
Donald J Trump is the third president in
history to be impeached that means we
are on to the final stage an impeachment
trial before the Senate so what's going
to happen and what are the rules if any
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer
because the president is going to trial
and he's going to need some good lawyers
well the Constitution contemplates a
trial this is very much unlike that kind
of trial you would normally see at your
local municipal courthouse first the
rules at play in this trial are very
much unknown there are no specific rules
of procedures for matters such as how
evidence is presented the scope of the
hearing and the witnesses unlike a
criminal trial at the state or federal
level where the rules of evidence and
the courtroom procedures are set usually
by statute here specific decisions on
these matters will be handled by a
simple majority vote by the Senate
second of all Chief Justice John Roberts
will be playing the role of the
presiding officer of this quote/unquote
trial think a judge but with more
ambiguous Authority still his role at
this trial adds some interesting
wrinkles that we'll talk about in just a
second both based on his judicial
disposition and past interactions with
the president and additionally all of
this is happening with the president
running for re-election in less than one
year given the whole fluidity of the
situation and the fact that the Senators
are going to have to act not only as the
jurors but the lawyers the judges and
the people that set the rules for the
judges this whole situation reminds me
of the improv game show whose line is it
anyway
you know the show where everything is
made up and the points don't matter
where drew Carey just picks whoever he
wants at the end and I guess in this
metaphor drew carey's Lindsey Graham on
tonight's show are the Democrat house
managers the Senate and presiding
officer Chief Justice John Roberts and
I'm your host
Deven Stone so legal eagles come on down
let's have some fun and make some stuff
up well at least we'll try to avoid
making anything up but let's talk about
the upcoming Senate impeachment trial
where little is known and almost
anything is possible but first the
question of whether there will actually
be a trial in the Senate recently
we've learned that Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi has intimated that she
intends to delay sending the articles of
impeachment from the house to the Senate
in order to provide leverage and force
the Senate to have a fair trial against
the president does Nancy Pelosi have any
legal basis for that well we're in sort
of constitutional gray areas here the
Constitution says the house has the sole
power of impeachment and that the
impeachment shall be tried in the Senate
but beyond that it's all sort of up in
the air and ambiguous certainly past
precedent indicates that this is not how
it has happened in the past with the
impeachment of President Clinton there
was not much of a delay between passing
the articles of impeachment in the house
and actually going forward with the
Senate in the trial with Nixon he
resigned before the Senate trial so this
situation simply never came up in all
the decisions I have made in my public
life I have always tried to do what was
best for the nation but because of the
constitutional ambiguities there's room
for both sides to argue that this is
allowable and that it's completely
improper additionally on a practical
level it's unclear what effect if any
this will have on the eventual Senate
trial first of all Congress is just
about to break for the winter holiday on
top of that it takes time for the House
to appoint the managers who effectively
act as the prosecutors and defendants
attorneys in the Senate trial and on top
of that the Senate still has to agree on
what rules will govern the Senate trial
itself so it's not like Congress is in a
position to move forward with the
impeachment trial anyway but people have
analogized a presidential impeachment to
an indictment in their criminal case the
indictment itself doesn't actually do
anything so the fact that the house has
impeached the president doesn't mean
anything until there is formal action in
the Senate in the same way that you can
get an indictment against a criminal
defendant and that won't have any effect
on their life until you actually move
forward with a trial that will either
convict them or acquit them of the crime
that they are accused of so it's not
necessarily in anyone's interest to
simply have an indictment or an
impeachment sitting out there in the
ether with having no effect on the press
of course it's not a good look to engage
in constitutionally dubious behavior
when you're accusing the other side of
violating the Constitution so given that
President Trump has been impeached but
that it has very little effect on the
presidency itself and without
constitutional guidance here I would
expect that this might be a delay of a
few weeks but eventually the Senate
trial will go forward because otherwise
the impeachment has no real effect so
first let's talk about the
constitutional language it actually
governs the impeachment proceedings to
date we can start with article 1 section
2 Clause 5 which states that the House
of Representatives shall choose their
speaker and other officers and shall
have the sole power of impeachment in
this case the House exercised their sole
impeachment power on December 18th by
formally impeaching President Donald
Trump on to articles of impeachment so
where does the Senate come in well for
that we have to look at article 1
section 3 Clause 6 which states that the
Senate shall have the sole power to try
all impeachments when sitting for that
purpose they shall be on oath or
affirmation when the president of the
United States has tried the Chief
Justice shall preside and no person
shall be convicted without concurrence
of two-thirds of the members present so
as to what procedures the Senate has to
follow the Constitution is largely
silent we know that the senators will
have to take an oath or affirmation that
the Chief Justice will preside over the
trial and that conviction and removal of
the president requires a two-thirds
majority of the Senators present at the
time so the vast majority of procedural
rules that are going to apply in this
particular trial are going to have to be
decided by the current sitting Senate
largely determined as a negotiation
between Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell and Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer they'll be decided as an
ad hoc basis for this particular
proceeding there are however some
helpful guidelines put out by Congress
in the publication called rules of
procedure and practice in the Senate
when sitting on impeachment trials so
let's try and flesh out some of the
Senate rules and guidelines that are
likely to shed light on what the trial
is going to look like in this particular
case first and ultimately of greatest
overall importance a vote of 2/3
or what's referred to as a supermajority
of the Senate is required for conviction
this is required by the Constitution and
no amount of Senate rules are going to
be able to change that specifically the
Senate impeachment rules state that if
the impeachment shall not upon any of
the articles presented be sustained by a
vote of two-thirds of the members
president a judgment of acquittal shall
be entered this can be distinguished
from the simple majority needed to
actually impeach the sitting president
now of course there is a big difference
between general impeachment of a
president and removal of office
impeachment occurs when the House says
it occurs and that's done by a simple
majority vote
whereas conviction and removal from
office happens only in the Senate and is
conducted by the Senators not
surprisingly but what about the trial
itself by way of background many frame
the whole impeachment process akin to a
criminal proceeding the House of
Representatives has the quote sole power
of impeachment which can be compared to
the indictment process in a criminal
proceeding basically this means that the
house is charged with making a formal
charge against the president however
it's the Senate which has the sole power
to quote try all impeachments acts as
both the jury and the judge by hearing
the evidence determining whether to
convict the president under the articles
of impeachment and if convicted to
determine the appropriate sentence as a
result of that conviction now many of
you legal eagles are probably thinking
right now but wait if the Senate is in
charge of the trial of the president and
we know that the Vice President is
tasked with presiding over the Senate
isn't there a conflict of interest
well yes but fear not because article 4
of the rules of procedure and practice
in the Senate when sitting on
impeachment trials states that when the
President of the United States or the
Vice President of the United States upon
whom the powers and duties of the office
of President shall have devolved shall
be impeached the Chief Justice of the
United States shall preside over the
Senate during the consideration of said
articles and upon the trial of the
person impeached therein so that means
Chief Justice Roberts not vice president
Pence will be the presiding officer for
this particular trial for the
impeachment trial the presiding officer
is given the power to make and issue
orders mandates writs and precepts
authorized by these rules and rule on
all questions of evidence including but
not limited to questions of relevancy
see materiality and redundancy of
evidence and incidental questions this
would seem to indicate that the Chief
Justice will have all of the power
afforded to a judge in a standard
hearing but there's a big but here the
presiding officers ruling shall be
accepted as the judgment of the Senate
quote unless some member of the Senate
shall ask that a formal vote be taken
thereon in which case it shall be
submitted to the Senate for decision
without debate so basically the
presiding officer has the power to make
these decisions but if the Senators do
not like the ruling they can override it
with a simple majority vote in fact
majority votes in the Senate can be used
to decide almost all key questions that
in any normal trial proceeding would be
decided by the judges under the law the
Senate itself wields a great deal of
power in control of this trial in
addition to being able to take any
decision by the Chief Justice to a
Senate vote it has the broad sweeping
responsibility of directing all
necessary preparations for the
consideration of impeachment articles
they can also quote compel the
attendance of witnesses enforce
obedience to its orders mandates writs
precepts and judgments punished in a
summary waken temps of and disobedience
to its authority and here's the big one
make all lawful orders rules and
regulations which it may deem essential
or conducive to the ends of justice for
all intents and purposes the Senate is
the Judge Judy an executioner with 53
Republicans in the Senate for the
Democrats to have any say in how this
trial will be conducted absent unlikely
bipartisan agreement it would require
more than three GOP defections on any
impeachment related motion which are
decided by simple majority votes so
let's talk about past precedent from the
past presidential impeachment hearings
it's been 21 years almost to the month
since the last presidential impeachment
hearing and this trial will only be the
third in the nation's history
so let's look to the rules that govern
the Clinton Senate impeachment trial to
see if we can glean any rules that will
likely occur in this particular case in
looking at the impeachment trial of
President Clinton there are two
particular observations that will be
helpful in assessing how a Senate
impeachment trial might look today first
a look at how the rules for the
trial were decided by a then divided
Senate similar to what we are dealing
with today and secondly the role of the
presiding officer then Chief Justice
William Rehnquist first looking at how
the rules were decided upon despite a
very divided Senate at the time all 100
senators voted to approve bipartisan
procedures for the Clinton impeachment
trial at the time Senate Majority Leader
Trent Lott famously worked with Senate
Minority Leader Tom Daschle to come up
with a set of rules for the impeachment
senator Daschle and I are not dictators
we are leaders that are getting some
latitude by our conferences and our
caucuses but we have to bring along 98
other senators the bipartisan agreement
settled on procedures such as allowing
24 hours for each side to present their
case followed by 16 hours for senators
to ask questions there was less
agreement however when it came to the
subject of witnesses a resolution
dealing with witnesses passed on a
strictly party line vote ultimately the
democratically controlled Senate chose
to only allow three witnesses per side
and they were all deposed privately in
the presence of a senator from each
party not actually in the Senate floor
during the course of the trial
now parts of their depositions were
shown by video during the trial
but despite Republican best efforts no
live testimony or cross-examination was
allowed now as far as chief justice
rehnquist impact on the Clinton
impeachment hearings based on most
accounts his most notable contribution
with the trial was a custom-made robe
with four gold stripes on each sleeve
Rehnquist was largely considered to have
taken a hands-off approach during his
role as the presiding officer in the
Clinton impeachment trial deferring to
the Senate on almost all matters in fact
Rehnquist himself is quoted as saying I
did nothing in particular and I did it
very well when he did make a ruling the
conservative chief justice was
considered by even Democrats do have an
even-handed approach for example in one
instance Rehnquist upheld an objection
from a Democratic senator regarding the
house managers referring to the Senate
as quote jurors Rehnquist stated the
Senate is not simply a jury it is a
court in this case for the most part
however Rehnquist left questions related
to witnesses and motions for the
Senators to negotiate he kept both sides
moving on schedule and mainly handled
proceed
objections the Democrats restricted the
Republicans from being able to conduct
the trial as extensive as they initially
wanted and Rehnquist didn't do anything
to interfere with that decision at the
end of the trial President Clinton was
acquitted on both articles of
impeachment brought before the
democratically controlled Senate perjury
before the grand jury and obstruction of
justice two-thirds of the Senators
present not having pronounced him guilty
so using the Clinton impeachment trial
as a template let's talk about the
current state of affairs with the
impeachment trial of Donald J Trump now
how the Trump impeachment trial is going
to play out procedurally the amount of
witnesses and the amount of evidence
ultimately allowed is anyone's guess so
is whether and which side would want to
attempt to lengthen or shorten this
trial to give you some frame of
reference the Clinton's Senate
impeachment trial lasted for five weeks
there are plenty of conflicting reports
about Republicans wanting to shorten the
impeachment trial or also wanting to
lengthen the impeachment trial to be
able to call witnesses like hunter Biden
or Nancy Pelosi sometimes we hear that
the president wants a very lengthy trial
to be able to prove his innocence and
sometimes we hear that he just wants to
get it over with now from the
president's thumbs himself on Twitter he
states that if you're going to impeach
me do it now fast so we can have a fair
trial in the Senate and so that we can
get our country back to business we will
have shift the Biden's Pelosi and many
more testify and we'll reveal for the
first time how corrupt our system really
is I was elected to clean the swamp and
that's what I am doing
similarly there have been conflicting
accounts of what the Democratic strategy
is going to be as well some say that
they simply want the Senate trial to be
conducted as quickly as possible to have
a strict vote on the articles themselves
and some want to be able to call the
firsthand witnesses that the Trump
administration has blocked from
participating in the impeachment
hearings before the house but both the
Republicans and the Democrats contain
multitudes so there may not be an
overarching strategy for either side but
given the fact that the rules or lack
thereof allow the Senate to create
almost any rules that they want nothing
is off the table the
republican-controlled Senate could
potentially depending on the rules set
proposed and pass a motion to dismiss
the charges before a formal hearing is
even conducted in addition they could
have a trial and either limit or
aggressive
expand the amount of evidence and
witnesses that are to be examined
they're not bound by a predetermined set
of rules that address matters such as
relevant evidence or hearsay as set
forth in the Federal Rules of Evidence
the Senate could adopt the federal rules
of evidence if they desired but the
Constitution doesn't mandate that they
do the status of witnesses is also up in
the air it's all reading tea leaves at
the moment it appears that the president
wants to call witnesses and that other
Republicans may not want that but the
thing about impeachment rules at least
historically is that they tend to be
symmetrical because it could always be
your party that's on the hot seat and so
history does provide a constraint
generally speaking whatever is allowed
for one party is generally allowed for
the other party as well now that isn't
necessarily how it has to go down the
Senate can make whatever rules at once
but because you never know who the next
president is to be impeached you
probably want to set a precedent of
reciprocity now interestingly polling
appears to show that the vast majority
of Americans are in favor of hearing
from the members of president Trump's
staff that have first-hand knowledge of
the whole Ukranian affair including
acting chief of staff and head of OMB
Mick bull vanie Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo and former national security
advisor John Bolton but the moment it's
incredibly unclear as to whether Senate
Republicans feel similarly in terms of
strategic considerations there are all
kinds of theories swirling about
Republican and Democratic motivations
about the Senate trial for instance some
believe that the Democrats are possibly
using the Senate impeachment trial as a
way to fast-track obtaining witness
testimony from key witnesses that were
subpoenaed in the house and refused to
testify or provide documents the theory
stems from the fact that the House of
Representatives did not go to court to
compel the testimony of no-show
witnesses such as national security
adviser John Bolton or Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo essentially the
argument is instead of waiting for
appeals to go all the way to the Supreme
Court where Chief Justice Roberts would
vote on these particular matters anyway
they could take it a shortcut and let
him make the decision as the presiding
officer during the Senate impeachment
trial it's certainly interesting but
there are a couple problems with this
series first the Senate rules already
state explicitly that they have the
power to compel witnesses the Democrats
most likely won't have the votes on a
motion to have these witnesses test
and second even if there is a scenario
in which Roberts makes a decision
regarding the testimony of those
witnesses that decision could be
overruled by a majority vote of the
republican-controlled Senate hanging
your hat on Republican senators
unwillingness to vote against a
conservative judge for political reasons
seems unlikely as far as what we can
expect from Chief Justice Roberts in his
role as the presiding officer of the
Senate trial is worth noting a couple of
things number one he is the former law
clerk of Chief Justice Rehnquist and he
identifies as an institutionalist who
prides himself as being protective of
the reputation of the court for example
Chief Justice Roberts once rebukes
President Trump after criticizing a
court ruling made by a quote Obama judge
Roberts said we do not have Obama judges
or Trump judges Bush judges or Clinton
judges what we have is an extraordinary
group of dedicated judges doing their
level best to do equal right to those
appearing before him indeed some of the
most recent Supreme Court cases where
Justice Roberts has voted with the
majority have shown extreme deference to
Congress in one particular case the
Supreme Court allowed representative
body to even gerrymander their own
geographical districts so in terms of
what you can expect from Justice Roberts
in the Senate impeachment trial probably
you can expect him to play it extremely
safe to not rock the boat and show
extreme deference to the Senators and
whatever they decide so how this trial
will look will largely be based on
either the hands-on or hands-off
approach of Chief Justice Roberts and
ultimately how the republican-controlled
Senate votes to set the rules for the
trial itself the bottom line is that
most major decisions are ultimately at
the discretion of the Senate itself
basically there are relatively few rules
that can stand in the way of a Senate
majority and most of them are fairly
easily changed what is certain however
is that if you're going to be a
defendant in trial even if you are the
president of the United States you need
a great-looking suit the last thing you
want to do is show up in court with a
tie that is 10 inches too long wearing a
jacket that is two sizes too big wearing
pants that are even too big for MC
Hammer
so mr. president if you're looking for a
custom slim cut suit that is shockingly
affordable I can't recommend Indochine
know highly enough all of my suits are
now made by endo Chino including
this blue - button that I'm wearing
right now which was custom-made just for
me because the secret of a great suit is
all about the fit I'm a reasonably
athletic guy and I can never buy suits
off the rack because they just simply
never fit right if the shoulders fit the
waist is too small and either it doesn't
fit or it costs a ton to have a tailor
fix it but with Indo Chino you can send
in your measurements online or you can
go to one of their stores and have a
stylist take your own personal
measurements my first time I made an
appointment I went to the store in
person had a stylist work with me for
over 90 minutes when I went in for the
first time my personal stylist took my
measurements and a couple weeks later I
got the best fitting suit of my entire
life it was perfect right out of the box
and if it wasn't endo Chino would have
tailored it for free endo chena will
make you a fully custom suit tailored
specifically for you for less than $400
and the best part is they still use the
best materials like super 140 s wool and
legal eagles can click the link in the
description to buy any premium Indo
Chino suit for only three hundred and
fifty nine dollars that is an insane
deal you can also use the promo code
legal eagle and if you go in in person
tell them legal eagle sent you I will
never buy an off-the-rack suit again and
once you try Indo Chino neither will you
legal eagles can get any premium Indo
Chino Soup for just three hundred fifty
nine dollars when you click on the link
below or use the promo code legal eagle
at checkout
clicking on the link in description
really helps out this channel so check
out Indo Chino com use the promo code
legal eagle for the best custom suit of
your entire life so do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist for
all of my other real law reviews over
here where I will see you in court